[Music]
this is Muriel Wooley she's got a chest
infection and she's struggling to
breathe as each hour passes the amount
of oxygen in her blood is dropping to
critical levels but a doctor has decided
that Muriel has reached the end of her
life and will die right here in this
room so this is my mom's care home rocks
Bay house this was as close as I forget
she was breathless and she needed some
kinds of oxygen or something to try and
make her feel better at this point we
knew she needs at the hospital she
needed the help and but unfortunately
she wasn't given that chance in the
middle of a national health emergency
doctors have made decisions about who
lives and who doesn't we all agreed that
this lady needed help and it was
completely denied virus if it was his
mom I'm sure that he'd want her to have
oxygen in this pandemic we look at
whether the elderly were placed at the
back of the queue when it came to
receiving hospital treatment we rang
quite a few times to get her a hospital
admission and that was denied she had a
right to be treated as an equal of any
other human being in the country and I
don't think she was because of her age
how do you go and tell someone of a
sound mind that thinks they could be
treated because they just got a chest
infection that they're gonna die
and what does this tell us about the
decisions that doctors have to make as a
society we do value the lives of younger
people more than older people and I
think across society most people will
feel that that's right should we be
doing this is this right can we learn
something is there any way that we can
explain that
so I think at the start of the pandemic
we were all very apprehensive
there was a very real concern that the
NHS would be overwhelmed with the
expectation that we'd see huge numbers
of patients coming into hospital we
didn't do so well as a health and care
system in how we planned with care homes
there's one section of society that's
admitted to hospitals more than any
other and that's people who live in care
homes many have thought about what the
end of their life might look like how
much treatment do they need and should
their heart stop do they want to be
brought back to life these wishes can be
put in writing they're called DNA CPRS a
DNA CPR order stands for do not attempt
cardiopulmonary resuscitation
so that means resuscitation by pressing
hard on the chest giving that person
oxygen when available and very
frequently ribs are broken in that
process but I think as doctors we always
have to think about what's the right
thing for our patient and that's
sometimes can be a difficult and nuanced
decision in late March early April some
health trusts and GP surgeries out of
the blue start to ring relatives whose
family members are in care homes to tell
them should they need hospital treatment
during the pandemic they won't receive
it
remember when Boris first said that you
know we're in a pandemic and that
everybody is going to be affected and
people are going to lose family members
and I got a call of sugar for olga brief
but didn't think i'd be affected so
badly
Toni Sweeney is 51 and has cerebral
palsy he's a big football fan and goes
to the match at least once a week in
April his sister Lisa found out a GP
asked his care home to put a DNA are on
every resident including him should
anyone get covered 19 yes I think
support a DNR on everybody you know and
even know people he's all football on my
brother who is very young heart and he
has a lot of life to live I think he's
an absolute disgrace when I found out at
the home it said you know that that
there was no way they were gonna do a
DNR on a 51 year old and they've got all
the young people I was really pleased
about that I thought you know I'm glad
there's somebody sticking up for them
lisa says it got worse on a phone call
with a GP she was asked about a DNA are
for her mum
Margaret Sweeney a resident in the same
care home as her son you're asking about
whether you want has your mom got a DNR
they're asking everybody about this for
people in in nursing homes she also said
that if she does have coded and she
needed oxygen then and she won't be able
to have it she said and it was too too
much for it be uncomfortable and that's
when I said well I'd rather it be
uncomfortable than dead and so with care
being discussed in advance it now
appears that some elderly people are
being maneuvered away from hospitals to
protect the NHS in the West Midlands
Helen Keenan was about to have a similar
conversation about her 84 year old mum
Kathleen she met my dad when she was 16
and he was 18 there were great pay
because she was very feisty and fiery
and he was very quiet and quite gentle
they had a good life you know on April
the 3rd an ambulance is called for calf
lene he's struggling to breathe because
of a chest infection because of the the
whole covert situation and her age I
spoke to the paramedics obviously wasn't
going to say anything official but he
just said you know they're not
necessarily admitting people that were
representing like your mother
did you find that reasonable or
unreasonable I thought it was totally
unreasonable and in the end they took
her to hospital and we weren't allowed
to go and then we would get a phone call
the next day from a doctor to give us
more information he said that she there
was a point scale and I think if he got
over eight points you weren't viable
this is called the clinical frailty
scale the NHS uses it to rank patients
vulnerability from 1 to 9 in order to
prioritize those most likely to recover
from a treatment basically she can
qualify for the bed so she needs to go
home it made me feel like if she had
just been written off as a human being
really Kathleen Keenan died a few days
later in April news of blanket DNA ours
finds its way into the inbox of an MP
constituents contact me about a whole
range of issues it was a Friday evening
and I received an email and sometimes
you really understand how distressed
somebody is when they sending it to you
her mother Vera watt was in a care home
in Salford and she had received a phone
call from somebody at the hospital
somebody who was a speech and language
therapist what she was basically saying
was that she had some kind of directive
or direction to contact the families of
residents in care homes and talk through
with them that they wouldn't be admitted
to hospital if they had coronavirus I
was shocked actually because I've some
experience of end-of-life planning and
understand the issues in it and it
should be done by clinician it should be
done by you know somebody's on GP by
somebody's a hospital consultant it
shouldn't just be done casually in a
phone call by somebody who doesn't have
training
the trust apologizes to variwatt and her
daughter for the way the call was
handled Salford NHS trust told us that
there's never been a policy to deny
hospital admission to care or nursing
home residents a few weeks later Vera
who is 79 falls ill again the hospital
admits her for treatment she's treated
and makes a full recovery I think it
told us two things really it tells us
that the focus was entirely on the NHS
and an acute sector and clearing people
out from hospital and not admitting
anymore we did get into a situation
where a hospital capacity was down to
about 55 60 percent in Greater
Manchester's we didn't have an issue
with whether people could be admitted to
hospital it was just a policy line that
they would not be
[Music]
in mid-april NHS England warns health
trusts and GPS not to use blanket DNA RS
calling them inappropriate it isn't
known how many families were contacted
during this time
my mom knew audial Wooley she was 73
years of age but a very young 73 years
of age she loved music she loved to ice
skate when she was younger three years
ago we found it on the floor and she's
had a bit of a for a few days later we
got told it was sepsis sepsis is a
potentially life-threatening condition
caused by the body's response to an
infection muriel fought sepsis not once
but twice in recent years muriel though
has chronic obstructive pulmonary
disease or COPD which means she often
struggles to breathe in april muriel or
mo to her friends falls ill again this
time with a chest infection
she is very unwell at a time when the
country is in the grip of a health
crisis the care manager at the care home
calls 999 Mohs oxygen levels in her
blood are below 50% dangerously low
she's given oxygen by a paramedic and
she responds well but when her GP is
called it's decided that mo will not go
to hospital but will end her life here
the paramedics are then liaised over the
telephone to a consultant sitting in a
hospital who's never met a lady who
didn't even ask to do a video call with
the lazy but his recommendation was she
stay at Roxburgh house and she was have
a couple of hours to live because
ultimately the way you breathing was and
the oxygen level she wouldn't live for a
couple of hours I was asked to go and
tell mo that she was gonna end their
life in the next couple of hours in
Roxbury house now that is the most
heartbreaking thing I have ever ever
been asked to do I had to go in the room
I had to come out the room I for time to
talk because how do you go and tell
someone of a sound mind that thinks he
could be cheated because they just got a
chest infection that they're gonna die
and she said boxing me why me why me
I don't got an answer I've got I
couldn't physically answer
a GP then video calls mo to put in place
that do not resuscitate order over the
phone explaining that she has just a few
hours to live would you say that she was
refused hospital treatment I was yes
definitely so and because I think at
that time she knew that she was she was
needing to go and at that point I you
know thought the same
so to obviously get that phone call to
say nothing's gonna happen I just wanted
an answer at that point I just wanted to
know why why wasn't she taken to a
hospital why wasn't she gonna get any
other help mo died in Roxburgh house
care home four days later the primary
cause of death is a chest infection in
part two we speak to the specialist
nurses who say they were left fighting
to get their elderly residents into
hospital it was in pain and discomfort
and breathless etc that didn't happen
and we look at how a relaxation in law's
junuh pandemic could stir up problems
from the past it could put a number of
people at risk because the whole process
of death investigation and desta
fication has been dumbed down because of
the pandemic tens of thousands of people
have died during this pandemic in some
cases Colvin is the known cause but in
others it's not so clear one big
question is where the hospital treatment
was denied to the elderly in order to
protect the NHS my name is Rachel hind I
have owned Faversham house since 1999 I
just want to talk a bit about the
activities what you're doing this
afternoon I am a trained nurse and
worked in intensive care for many years
okay all right thanks dawn I shall see
you later I'm just gonna see Johnny
hello there's only one Johnny walls all
right our philosophy of care is to treat
all our residents just with respect and
dignity and help them enjoy the last few
years of the line so we have 20 service
users this is a specialist nursing home
the nurses have decades of experience
working here and in the NHS
but during the pandemic they say it
became increasingly difficult to get
Hospital treatment for residents and
I've come to find out why that is we had
a lady who had all the signs of the
symptoms of lower respiratory tract
infection she was unwell she was at
fever we wanted her to have a hospital
admission we wanted it to have IV
antibiotics and we wanted her to have IV
fluids so we weren't allowed to send her
into hospitals she was put on oral
antibiotics here and we were denied the
Cova testing we asked for oxygen and we
were denied it
it was a shot all the nurses that day we
knew what we all agreed that this lady
needed immediate help and it was
completely denied so this lady was
flatly denied medical treatment and you
say there's no excuse for it yes there's
no excuse saying it we just felt like we
were just left and pushed to one side
that that day I felt like a second-class
sister it was horrible
sounds like she might have suffered
needlessly if she did suffer no she was
let down wasn't sure yeah and now she's
passed away and my question is that in a
pandemic
when hospitals are busy as that is that
a justification no whatsoever whatsoever
she was still happily living her life in
her own little way wasn't sure yeah yeah
why should she be there denied that it's
just it's it's just unethical
care homes and the NHS begin to drift
further and further apart and care homes
are asked not only to care for residents
in house but take on a major role
normally carried out by a visiting GP
the recording of deaths at the time the
government was building temporary
morgues fearing a sudden rise in deaths
any delays in recording them could see
places like this begin to fill up the
coronavirus Act given Royal Assent at
the beginning of the pandemic relaxes
the rules around how deaths are verified
and certified in care homes to make sure
there are no delays in processing the
dead the Department of Health and Social
Care said the changes to death
certification had allowed public
services to manage during the pandemic
while allowing funerals to take place
dr. harold frederick ship them driven
away to Strangeways prison tonight knows
he will now spend the rest of his days
behind bars but could there be a more
worrying unintended consequence to these
changes some of these safeguards were
introduced following the conviction of
dr. Harold Shipman who murdered more
than 200 elderly patients in his care
Shipman was able to get away with it
because of weaknesses in the way deaths
were certified and so during the crisis
GPS are advised to avoid entering care
homes primarily to stop the spread of
kovat 19 but at the same time crucially
the law now allows care homes to
nominate a competent member of staff who
can now verify the deaths of elderly
residents in the absence of a doctor a
doctor therefore doesn't need to be
there we've seen evidence that care
providers were deeply concerned by this
here's an email between one care home
owner and a local NHS official talking
about verification of death or VOD for
short I think it is a tall task of homes
right now to assess competency for VoD
where majority of homes are fighting
Kovac
if you are expecting us to verify death
during this time it should not fall back
to individual care homes we need
protecting we're all nervous under
pressure and scared so some care homes
are left struggling to get hospital
treatment for their elderly residents
whilst at the same time shouldering
greater responsibility for making sure
that deaths are recorded properly
with difficult decisions being made
about who receives care and who doesn't
I want to know where the law stands when
it comes to some of the stories I've
heard from relatives of elderly
residents I'm Emma Jones I'm a partner
in the human rights department at the
lead a my area special ism is in human
rights and also in treatment and care of
older people in care homes hospitals
whether or not their treatment is
different to treatment that a younger
person would receive I I do understand
that it's a very very difficult time for
doctors nurses health care providers and
and these sorts of things had to be
thought about but to to put out a
directive or a blanket policy I would
question whether or not that that such a
decision would be lawful who seemed
people being discharged from hospitals
into care homes of kovat is that because
the hospital doesn't want over it
spreading in the ward but it's okay for
it to spread through a care home and
then we would ask well why is that what
is the demographic of individuals in
macao and probably older and with care
homes closed to visitors staff verifying
deaths and fewer doctors to oversee
events care homes could be seen as less
regulated now than they were before the
pandemic it could put a number of people
at risk because the whole process of
death investigation and death stiff
occation has been dumbed down because of
the pandemic but it seems to me that we
are now in a position where there isn't
an investigation or there doesn't need
to be an investigation and deaths
potentially aren't being accurately
recorded so are we back in a time as it
was pre doctor
the Department for Health and Social
Care says that treatment for any
individuals should be based on an
informed discussion between the patient
and their treating clinician but that's
not been experienced for some of the
people we've spoken to is it right for a
doctor to tell someone that they're
gonna die over FaceTime no that doctor
should have come this care home that
doctor should have used PPE whether it
be a gown whether it be a suit whether
it be goggles whether it be visors we've
got the facilities here why couldn't
they come in and say to this lazy did
they not easy but that bit of dignity
that little bit of respect do you think
it's fair to say that within a pandemic
it was always going to be that the
elderly were not going to receive as
much treatment as the younger
demographics so as a society we do value
the lives of younger people more than
older people and I think across society
most people would feel that that's right
is it fair to say that because of that
the system was stacked against the
elderly the system was certainly stacked
against older people in care homes
how do you feel about these big
decisions being made with a GP and a
patient over FaceTime in a care home in
a pandemic that's obviously very
suboptimal in terms of what we would all
want as a way of making these decisions
but in a pandemic there may not be an
alternative
so can lessons be learnt in case the
virus returns we really do need a public
inquiry to be looking into these issues
to explore whether or not there there
have been mistakes and failings and are
things any better now than at the
beginning of the pandemic are you still
feeling the pressure not to admit to
hospital today yes I think so I don't
think anything's changed massively we
will not allow people to be ignored just
because they live in a care home setting
it presumed that because she's old
because she's got code then she's a
goner and after a couple days she heard
something she was great if you look at
just this one case of error with
antibiotics and oxygen she came back to
the care home and recovered so you know
how many more people were in that
situation and can people ever come to
terms with losing a loved one like this
this is the first time that you've been
back since she died I mean how does it
feel to be back at this window it's
awful and it's all for being here and
knowing that she's not there it's very
very hard and now when this was the last
Hanul escena
love you Millions